Beauty stems from the eye of the beholder, but because the continuation of humanity is driven by sexual selections
We often try to highlight what makes us unique. Well what exactly exists
In make-up products? Should we trust its components to put in our bodies?
Does makeup really hurt you?
Historically, the ancient Egyptians carved metal materials consisting mainly
Of lead sulphide and put it around their eyes to get the look of an attractive, ignorant Kelopatra
Lead is a strong neurotoxin which can lead to learning difficulties and behavior
In children, the fertility rate decreases in both men and women. Recently in 1891, creams and lotions
The red ingredients containing radioactive radium components were also sold to women
In Europe, which is considered a bright youth - until the discovery of harmful radiation effects
But make-up has come a long way and now holds small amounts of lead
In our products. Lead is found in nature and is an unintentional contaminant from industrialization.
The Food and Drug Organization examined 400 cans of lipstick and found different concentrations of 0.026 million
To 7.19 million of lead. Which are within Canada's health limits of "10 million".
Lipstick contains 47% of oils, 36% of dyes, 17% of wax, 5% of other ingredients including
Preservatives. Oils based on castor oil, extracted from beans, which contains
Resin protein - one of the most toxic substances on the planet which is used
As a vital weapon. However, the process of extracting castor oil depends on heating
Which disintegrates the ricin and makes it inactive.
Dyes are now used in industrial dyes because of the cost and efficiency of production although the conventional way
In the extraction of red dyes are from dried and pollinated cinnamon insects. Some blue dyes
It is made of ferrocyanide iron, high-risk cyanide but in this product
The cyanide compound is associated with a strong bond with the iron. As a result, it is unable
To be our Sam in the shadows of the eyes.
When talking about the mascara, we recommend removing the container after three months of opening it.
Where he discovered the growth of harmful streptococcus bacteria and types of fungi by 36.4%
In cans of mascara. This is important for contact lens repellents, where bacteria can
Easily enter through small scratches in the lens itself
Paraben was a major concern as well as used in beauty products
Paraben mimics the action of estrogen and can bind to estrogen receptors. This can cause
Change in gene formula and change communication between cells .. In addition to
It can lead to the growth of breast cancer cells. However, a lot of products are going to be
Free of paraben - and we still need a lot of studies to come up with results
Conclusive